Eric is selling raffle tickets
for a school fundraiser.
Each ticket costs $3, and he
knows the amount of money he
collects is a function of how
many tickets he sells.
What are the domain and range
for that function?
So let's write the
function for how
much money he collects.
So I'll call that m, the
function will be m, and it's a
function of how many
tickets he sells.
So it's a function of
t, for tickets.
So m, the amount of money
collected, is a function of
the number of tickets
he sells.
That's a pretty straightforward
function.
Every ticket costs $3.
He gets $3 for every ticket.
So it's going to be 3 times
t dollars or 3t dollars.
That's how much money
he collects.
Now they ask us, what
are the domain and
range for that function?
It sounds all fancy and
difficult, but just remember
the domain, this just
means, what can I
input into the function?
So another way to think about
is what are the possible t's
that can be input into
this function?
The range is, what are the
possible values that the
function can take on?
So think about it.
You might at first say I could
put any t there, but think
about the actual reality
of what he's doing.
He's selling tickets,
and so he can't
sell negative tickets.
He might sell 0 tickets,
and he might
sell a gazillion tickets.
I guess he could sell an
infinite amount of tickets.
At some point that becomes
unrealistic.
But he definitely can't
sell negative tickets.
He also is not going to
sell half of a ticket.
Every ticket he sells is a whole
number, it's an integer.
So the domain for this function,
we could say t has
to be a non-negative integer.
I think that covers what
I just talked about.
Non-negative.
Instead of saying positive,
because it could be 0.
He might literally
sell no tickets.
He can't sell a negative 1
ticket or negative 2, so it's
anything that's non-negative.
It has to be an integer, he
can't sell half of a ticket,
so, and he definitely-- it
has to be an integer.
So that's our domain,.
And let's think about
what our range is.
A range is the possible values
that we can take on.
If t is always going to be a
non-negative integer, then
what's 3t always going to be?
Well it's going to be a
non-negative multiple of 3.
So non-negative multiples
of 3.
Think about it.
He'll never be able to collect
$2, because he could either
sell 0 tickets and
get nothing.
Let me write this down.
He might sell 0 tickets, so m
of 0, he's going to get $0.
m of, if he sells one ticket,
he's going to get $3.
If he sells two tickets,
he's going to get $6.
So he's never going to be
able to get 2 or 4.
Every possible value for the
amount of money he collects
for our function has to
be a multiple of 3.
It's going to be a non-negative
multiple of 3
because the domain is
non-negative integers.